dans cette poissonnerie on achète la
grande majorité des produits directement
à la source - iliad intermédiaires moins
il ya de chances qu'un poisson soit mal
étiquetés c'était pas un professionnel
quelqu'un qui s'en sert comme qui fait
ça comme métier plutôt ça peut être
difficile de reconnaître les espèces
parce que beaucoup de poissons qui vont
se rassembler l'organisme oceana a
effectué des tests d'adn sur des
poissons vendus en épicerie et dans les
restaurants
résultat près de la moitié des produits
sont identifiés de façon trompeuse au
pays à montréal et à toronto
ces six poissons sur dix sont mal
étiquetés en penses qu'on achète à du
saumon sauvage par exemple mais en fait
c'est du saumon d'élevage où on a testé
des espèces comme du vivaneau est pour
nous dans 100% des cas où on a testé le
vivant non en fait c'était une autre
espèce souvent c'était du tilapia qui
est un poisson beaucoup moins cher sa
peau de sam jeudi au nouveau un produit
évidemment que reconnaître un prochain
parmi tant d'autres c'est pas évident
pour nous les médecins disent ma récente
et on a fait confiance sur ce que les
distributeurs nous disent on n'a pas
grand contrôle là dessus dans cette
usine de transformation tous les
produits sont dûment étiquetées selon
les normes fédérales
d'après le directeur général des erreurs
de bonne foi peuvent survenir plus loin
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement mais
des poissons peuvent aussi être
présentées de façon trompeuse par
certains restaurateurs dans l'ue menu sa
part m une barre quinton route par
exemple que de marquer des essais de
temps si tu sens que je sais c'est sale
une connotation plus dispendieux on doit
se fier nous à skis et l'étiquetage qui
est dans le bon de commande qu'on a reçu
donc souvent même le restaurateur et
berné c'est trop tentant par exemple de
remplacer un produit qui qui coûte cher
par aux restaurateurs ou à l'épicier par
quelque chose qui qui peut coûter moins
cher puisque le consommateur voit pas sa
rencontre selon lui les autorités
réglementaires doivent effectuer
davantage de tests d'adn sur des
poissons vendus
pis rit on restera pour s'assurer que le
consommateur ont bel et bien ce qu'ils
veulent dans leur assiette ici olivier
bassand radio canada montréal